una gran celebración para festejar su
victoria en virginia
glenn young quien que se convirtió en el
primer republicano en ganar el estado
desde 2009
juntos cambiaremos la trayectoria de
esta mancomunidad y amigos vamos a
empezar esa transformación el primer día
[Música]
young kim un rico ex empresario y recién
llegado a la política vio como sus
posibilidades aumentaban en las
encuestas al final de la campaña cuando
se centró en la educación tomando
prestada esta estrategia de los
demócratas prometió más inversión en las
escuelas públicas y arremetió contra la
teoría crítica de la razón un análisis
académico sobre el racismo sistémico en
las instituciones estadounidenses la
teoría crítica de la raza incómoda para
los medios de comunicación de la derecha
estadounidense no se enseña en las
escuelas de virginia y muchos de los
votantes que la tachan como un problema
no están familiarizados con sus
principios esto sin embargo permitió a
john kings apelar a la base de donald
trump sin apoyar realmente al ex
presidente cuyo estilo político divisivo
y a menudo engañoso lo hizo muy
impopular entre los votantes
independientes en el estado rechazo que
ayudó al presidente joe biden a ganar en
virginia por 10 puntos en 2020 todos los
virginianos merecen que se cuenten sus
votos
el oponente demócrata de jong quien el
ex gobernador de virginia terry
macauliffe trató de vincular al
republicano con trump sin éxito ahora
los demócratas se enfrentan la
posibilidad de malos resultados en las
elecciones de mitad de mandato para el
congreso del próximo año el índice de
aprobación de bailén se ha hundido hasta
el 42% afectado por la caótica retirada
de eeuu de afganistán la recuperación
económica de la pandemia de kobe 19 y
las luchas internas del partido
demócrata que han frenado la agenda
legislativa del presidente